hey guys Ryan Wright is here Wow you do
look good thank you
I just showered one of those rare
occasions so today we're gonna check out
the video Matthew McConaughey's reaction
to the Star Wars teaser number two I
really do want to watch this I think
Matthew McConaughey is a fantastic actor
but he's also really cool when he's
parodied I'm excited too because there's
a girl here and a lot of you guys lately
are like Ryan what's up where is all the
girls on the channel so you're all are
alike watch this video already I can't
because I feel pressured to bring this
on let's just look pretty
it's already [ __ ] funny
[Music]
I had
[Music]
I feel I go imaginary over yet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow that was so good that was [ __ ]
brilliant I did not realize how they
were gonna make that video I like the
title but I didn't realize they were
gonna make it like a legit trailer that
was well edited whoever thought of doing
that is brilliant and they could do that
for like a bunch of other videos and I
won't give a [ __ ] oh I'll keep watching
this one that was great thank you guys
for telling us seriously thank you for
telling us if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
and you can follow salamander Sally on
Sally's channel oh the Sally Channel
mm-hmm that is the length of Nick's
penis Wow it's like The Incredible Hulk
yes so good you follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter
we're gonna do a shout out
Elizabeth paneer paneer anyway Elizabeth
paneer I noticed as a female subscriber
trying to acknowledge more females now I
noticed she's a female subscriber who
comments a lot lately and there was one
comment can't find her right now
where she just went off about how that's
one person finally you know everyone
else is like okay you don't do anything
for you you just watch straight news Oh
dick yeah that's true but Elizabeth
understands that sometimes that's just
the man's lifestyle and so she's
constantly commenting Thank You
Elizabeth for being one of the female
subs one of the five I believe yeah you
know I remember some other ones
Savannah wild listen to Lindsey Nick and
NEX I know it sounds like it would be a
guy right Michelle Fernandez well [ __ ]
have you been Michelle we was talking a
lot before you know I got a Veronica
what's up what's up what's up you should
be happy for me Michelle
it's probably why should stuff yeah -
real - real this is not Elizabeth
Elizabeth thank you thank you so you're
a beautiful woman gorgeous if you ever
feel insecure about anything you want
like plastic surgery there's nothing
about you that's imperfect I've even
seen your photo yet actually I will pay
for it don't say that because no I'm
putting this on camera I will pay for
your surgery